I'm doing this movie with Snoop and  basically you know Snoop is a big peewee  football guy he's been coaching for  [ __ ] years so he made essentially  he's making like Bad News Bears but with  peewee football yeah so he's the coach  of like the underdog team the movie's  called iron dogs and I'm the coach of  the like the bougie team I'm like the  villain yeah so uh yeah it's fun and  Snoop is like I've like done films with  some people now and like acted with some  people now and some of them have ego and  some of them don't and he is by far the  most encouraging person I've ever been  on really that's fine that like  literally goes hey man this is your  scene like just go for it rip oh that  Line's really funny keep that one in  really and the the lines are making fun  of his character sometimes you have an  ego even about your character yeah and  he's just like nah just just go for it  like I thought it was so cool man she's  just a man